is a really high complexity in the in
the wiring up of the nerve cells so that
could be between High computation but
then all of the cells would be operating
using what's essentially a binary code
so I called it a machine code which I
don't not Everyone likes but I think
it's a kind of like every single cell in
the body
would be operating with this mechanical
interdependency between all the cells
which would be at the base level would
be at the the binary level of these
switches
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video I spoke
with Ben gold professor of biochemistry
at the University of Kent where his lab
researches the mechanical basis of
memory and the role of the protein Talen
as an information storing molecule
this then refers to as the mesh code
Theory we discussed this theory of
memory and More in our discussion enjoy
so hi Ben thank you for joining me today
and welcome to the Shiki Science Show
hi Elena thank you um yeah it's great to
be here thank you so actually I came
across your research first probably back
in 2020 and so I feel bad that was
taking me so long to finally reach out
to you to actually get you to come onto
the channel
um because your match codes uh theory is
super interesting and I'll be really
excited to get on to that later in this
discussion but I thought just to begin
with
um one thing we just sort of discussed
and I sort of just jumped through a
sense of the question what is
mechanobiology and what is this whole
subject area about okay so McKenna
biology is an exploding area of
um biology
um and a lot of realization over the
last um decade or so that all the cells
in our body and all the cells in all
animals and all cells in all organisms
really uh very sensitive to physical
forces
um
flow different pressures and different
movements so basically mechanibology is
the trying to understand how forces
impact on biology and the different ways
that cells can sense and respond to them
and how that can ultimately be important
for
the formation of higher orders of
complexity because each cell can respond
to different mechanical signals so
probably what it is
and so you'll see that combines both
like biology and physics and probably a
bit of engineering so how what is your
backgrounds and how does that how did
you get into the skills yes so I got
into this
basically it was an experiment which we
did
um over over a decade ago which got me
into meccano biology which has but prior
to that I was a biochemist I did a
degree in Biochemistry and then I did a
PhD in in drug Discovery and approaches
to
um measure drugs binding to proteins and
then I did a post I went back
um
and then I did my postdoc which was on
is actually on postsynaptic density and
psd95
after that I went into industry for a
year and a bit to work on drug Discovery
but then I got while I was doing my drug
Discovery at AstraZeneca
um one of the things I was tasked with
was to
um
test all of the different NMR software
packages and choose which one was the
best and which one they might adopt and
this sounds a bit
um esoteric but one of the things one of
the new ones the state of the art ones
was a program called ccpn and the guy
who was making a lot of the scripts for
it happened to work on tailing and he
sent me
um protein and data and these scripts so
I spent the last six months of my time
atrazeneca working on tailing and it
worked really nicely and then he said oh
you should come and have an interview so
in 2006 I actually came back into
Academia to work on this protein called
tailing which is I assume most of this
interview is going to be talking about
and since then I've just had
um the most amazing journey following um
how tailing functions what it does
starting from these very basic view of
it just as an adapter protein up to
where we are now of this um really
complex mechanical
um protein and I was a straight
biochemist structural biologist until we
made a discovery where we had a region
of tailing one of these domains which
was doing a different job it had two two
things it did one when it was folded and
one when it was unfolded so it had to
change its shape as a function of force
was the hypothesis so it got stretched
and then it did a different job after
that so we found a switch
and then after that I got in touch with
um
a guy called professor yanji in in
Singapore who there's a whole
mechanobiology Institute in Singapore
and I said we found this switch how hard
would I really want to know how hard you
have to pull to open this and then that
just set us on this journey with me and
G just exploring what tailing did and
got us to where we are today and so
that's how I got into my kind of biology
just from finding as an experimental
finding of two different ligands binding
to the two different proteins which
bound to the same small part of the
taline molecule in different states
so yeah exactly as you say we're
probably going to be talking a lot about
tailing so just to keep my get my fears
um up to the same level uh how would you
describe the tail end like what is its
structure and how does that fit into
like mechanic sensing of the cell like
what does it mean to say an adapter
protein no that's a very good question
so I should have said that so when I
first started with um Dave critchley's
Lab at Leicester in 2006 it was well
established by that time that Taylin was
the part of the adhesion complexes which
hold all ourselves in place so on the
edge of all of ourselves as these
receptors called integrins and these can
physically grab onto this
underlying extracellular Matrix so all
of our cells in our body attach onto
this Matrix and that provides
instructions on how they should behave
and the integrins on the inside of the
cells are bound to these proteins called
tailing and tailing connects the
integrine and the external Matrix
complexes to the cytoskeleton this um
mesh work inside the cell of force
generating Machinery like actin and
sites like and so tailing sits there so
when I first started on it tailing was
um very little relatively little was
known about what it looked like or and
it was just considered to be an adapter
so one of the first tasks we did was to
work out what the molecule looks like
and that's how we discovered that
there's 13 of these what we now know are
binary switches in there it's got 13 of
these folded helical bundles which are
the switches which are the idea of this
Theory
um and
what was interesting was we were working
on this and it was just considered to be
this adapter
but it was really strange because it's
completely the same in every single
animal right down to slime mold and
every single animal up in evolutionary
complexity and over that Holy
evolutionary time it's always had
exactly the same domain structure
and they're all in the same order these
switches and a lot of the residues which
a lot of the amino acids which are
important in us are perfectly conserved
in the slime molds in the soil in your
garden so clearly this molecule appeared
and then has been maintained all the way
through animal development and animal
evolution
and so that's what tailing is it's this
essential adapter and it is essential
because if you don't have it it's it's
lethal and there's not many mutations
which
um are viable where where
the organism develops correctly and so
so Taylor is expressed in all cell types
is that right
um yes there's two there's two tailings
um
and
tell him one and tailing two tailing
one's quite broad um you pick it's in
all of our cells tailing two is also in
all of our cells but tailing two tends
to be enriched in heart and in the brain
so they've got slightly different
um where they're where they're expressed
where they've they're found
um but yeah that is in all cells
so I actually already mentioned you've
spoken about these different domains and
how they have this like unfolded and
folded States and I have to put I'll
probably um in post editing put some
pictures to sort of explain what this
really means but when you go from this
folder to unfolded State there's this
massive increase
um in length that can be generated
um and so that sort of LED on to this um
Mexico Theory which you um written now a
couple of articles on and so I was
wondering if you could explain how you
went from just looking at the structure
and this sort of meccano sensing of this
protein to having this uh like theory
for coding binary information and so
yeah into memory so yeah there's a bit
of a step there and it was a conceptual
it was like a conceptual change in my
thinking so what I'd say is for the
explaining what these switches look like
the the animations which we've now made
it'd be very nice if you could show
those because there would physically
show what this opening and closing of
these domains looks like and the opening
and closing of the domain and the
switches the flicking of the switches
that's all experimental we can show that
at
um at different levels with single
molecule we can physically manipulate
these molecules so we can we can show
Absolutely experimentally and
definitively that these switches exist
that they open and close independently
and we can also show that they've got
this key Point called molecular memory
because if you stretch a tail in
molecule so you get a certain pattern of
so we call the folded domain zero and
then the open domains one just because
there's two states there's a closed and
an open
if you have a tail in which is in a
certain pattern and you hold it it will
stay in that pattern for minutes in the
in our experiments and if you have
things which stabilize those patterns
and they can be very long-lived so the
idea of mechanical memory we sort of
we're all kind of discussed it back in
2016 but the real change in the thinking
was if you look at a cell in culture so
a lot of Cell Biology is done by looking
at cells in under a microscope in there
these adhesion structures are quite
dynamic they only last
like the turnover the molecules is tens
of seconds so they're quite short-lived
um but the idea came that if these cells
become ordered like in a in a in our
brain I don't think the adhesions are
constantly assembling and disassembling
every 10 seconds I think they become
ordered
and that higher ordering of the
molecules led to the idea that this
higher these switches these patterns of
information
could be more persistent and they could
be more much more ordered and more
specific than what we currently imagine
so that changing thinking came from a
very simple idea actually and it was
when I was in Australia I'd just been to
give a talk in Sydney and
um a guy there called Peter gunning
asked me a question he says so you
showed this nice tailing unfolding and
refolding but that's just one tailing
molecule there's a hundred in a Cell how
do they all work together
and I've sat at Sydney airport I'm
trying to think about it and then it was
like the only way you could bring that
together is if it's in the system is
ordered if they're all working together
and
um and then if they're all ordered then
you can have
much more
um yeah organization and I think the
organization of the cells is probably
much higher in our body and particularly
in our brain than what we currently
think from our current from the
limitations we're trying to physically
visualize a selling culture which is
already quite complicated
um so that was the big step because then
you could have an idea
where
if you've got a cell which is moving
around then the forces experienced by
each tailor molecule uh
in part from outside the movement and
also from inside the the motives and the
fourth generation machinery
however if the outside is relatively
constant if the cell makes its ECM Nest
perfectly then that becomes constant and
then the cell can
control the switches from inside by
switching on its motor proteins and
pulling and it was that step change
because then I thought like there then
the cell can be in total control of that
and that was led to this massive
um idea from that initial thought oh you
could write data into these adhesions to
oh these adhesions are essential for
holding every synapse in the brain
together
um to oh what if these synaptic scaffold
binary switches were a way to write
information but also coordinate the
activity of that synapse and maybe we'll
get on to that that's in the latest
story let me just turn off my watch Taxi
anything I don't want that
um so that's the general idea that's
where we got uh where I got to where we
are
um and that's the general basis of the
mesh code that there's a mesh worker buy
a new switches in all of our cells but
in a higher ordering inside the synapses
of our brain where these neurons that
nerve cells are talking to each other
via these connections yeah so I've got
like several follow-up questions to that
and so just a sort of some ways to make
sure that I've kind of understood this
correctly you can somewhat as we've
described of Taylor and having these
folded and unfolded regions
some sort of like mechanical spring
within a cell attached to you both like
actin filaments within the cell but also
connected three integrines to the actual
cellular matrix outside the cell and so
in theory if he had forces from either
side you could sort of stretch it from
both directions but you're saying that
within the brain on maybe with other
tissues as well there's more of a fixed
force or continuous sort of
um sensing from The extracellular Matrix
that the talent is responding to
internal signals within the cell is that
correct yeah so it's returned so that's
very nice it's succinctly described but
yeah the idea would be that these
synapses because they you've got like
the say dendrite and you've got these
little spines sticking up and then
they've got their little bulb on and
they're talking these are like isolated
mechanical units from the rest of the
cell because they've got this long shaft
and then this thing like if you think
about the tailings on the bottom of the
cell then they've got lots of different
variables and different things but the
cells of the brain is well established
from lots of stunning work looking at um
ECM maintenance that the they invest a
huge amount of energy into making the
ECM how they want it to be
um and there's loads of things where
that goes wrong but then if the ECM
becomes how so the cell knows what it's
like then it doesn't mean it's not
changing but it means that the cell when
it pulls it's it's a predictable outcome
which can be generated from in within
and what's been shown by other
researchers is that the synaptic
transmission where the synapse want the
presynaptic releases the vesicle into
the into the cleft and then that's up to
by the postsynaptic that's been that's
well shown to increase
um
changes in the cytoskeleton and
switching on of the motor proteins in
the postsynaptic side so what the idea
here is that these well-established
things which have been shown by the
neuroscientist Community they would be
orchestrating the operation of these
taline molecules and these switches in a
way that you could actually capture
these events in a in a quantized
um State like by flicking a switch so
that's the idea so what I like the
downstream functional consequences of
having Taylor and these different folds
and unfolded states
yes so that's another very good question
and
what I was shown in a long time um not a
long time it's all relative I suppose
but 15 years ago from um
Adam angler and Dennis dishes lab was
that they could take a stem cell and put
it onto different Matrix different
surfaces which are coded in Matrix and
they could get that stem cell which is
undifferentiated to differentiate into
lots of different lineages and the trick
that they did was they kept everything
constant the only thing they varied was
the the stiffness of the Matrix this
cell was sat on so if they sat the cell
on Jelly it would differentiate and
become a fat cell or nerve cell and if
they sat it on a matrix which was on
glass it'd become a bone cell so what's
happened is that those cells have
grabbed on they've interrogated what
they're attached to and then that's
ultimately led to this process called
mechanic transduction which is where the
sellers converted those mechanical
forces and transduced them into changes
in the gene expression and the behavior
of the cell so the idea in
in the magical Theory but that would be
happening on a much more complex well
not more complex than that but each of
these
um synapses would be updating
um
and that would have an effect on the
gene expression and the mechanic
transduction of that neuron
and because each
um synapse will be getting signals from
different neurons then they would be
talking to each other in this way by a
signal coming from one cell to the next
cell and then that would do a
calculation and then that might trigger
to another cell and then you could get
this whole circuit which would be being
updated by this
mechanic transduction in a high provided
system in a perfectly ordered system I
try and argue but
um and that would be the general idea I
suppose
because in terms of like thinking about
um memory in synaptic transmission
there's often a lot of talk about the
strength of the connections and
um that being linked to like memory
formation but I guess from your theory
it's more about
the the speed of the downstream
consequences following the synaptic
connection is more encoded into how the
tailoring is structured
so yes and no so what I think and I
think the one of the strengths of the
idea is it's consistent with the current
thinking of this electrical and chemical
signaling of the brain that's taking
place but what will be happening
underneath the hood would be this
mechanical computation where that
electrochemical signaling would be
um coordinating these motor proteins to
change these patterns of information
written into the shape of these
molecules
because that's kind of what I'm saying
is that the information is written into
the shape of these tailored molecules
within each of the synapses but one of
the big questions we got after well yeah
I got but then talking to lots of people
the common question was like how would
those changes in this binary pattern
actually change the activity of the
synapses which is why this new paper
which came out last um two weeks ago
okay we started to try and understand
why how would these changes in the shape
of molecules and change the signaling
and change the which synapses have got
high activity in which have got low
activity and all the variations in
between and there we started off when we
were trying to build a simulation of
tailing mechanical response which was a
bit ambitious in retrospect but within
about
a week of trying to do that we spotted
something much more simple but much more
obvious and much more
um important I think in that as as you
said at the start these switches opening
they as well as changing what ligands
bound to that switch which proteins are
on it they also introduce a big jump in
the extension so a domain when it's
folded is is five nanometers when it's
open it can stretch as fast 50
nanometers so it's got 10 times longer
but the main implication of that is it's
got 10 times longer its signals change
but every single switch after that has
also moved and the active cytoskeleton
has also moved that far in so
what we get to is we get this idea that
these and the best example we've got of
this in fact I'm saying this a bit back
to front is we've got a whole series of
enzymes which sit on tailing on these
switches so enzymes
um have substrates which they either
phosphorylate or they acetylate or they
change they provide a chemical change
too
and these enzymes which are sat on these
switches
have substrates within the synapse so
it's if you've got an enzyme and a
substrate right next door to each other
then this can easily modify that but if
you physically hold them a long way
apart like if the switch in the middle
would open and these are now held apart
then the activity is really really low
because this can't actually reach to
that so the idea would be that there'd
be patterns there'd be codes very
combinations of these switches where all
of the enzymes have been lined up
and then other ones where they were held
apart which would have very low activity
and that was the idea in this new paper
well not the idea the realization that
this old organization of molecules in in
the Z Dimensions you'd have the
that's how the hands you have to sign up
yeah with all the tailoring molecules
attached coming down then if this is the
X and Y Dimension then Z going away like
the down the sign up you'd organize all
of the enzymes and substrates in this Z
Dimension so you'd have some some which
would be really efficient and really
active synapses and then some which
would be
um have low activity and if you looked
at them with a microscope or you looked
what was in them there would be
relatively little change because it'd be
the same molecules that'd just be
organized differently and they'll be
organized based on the signals that that
specific synapse that we see so that
would be how a binary code would convert
into a
regulation over like a neural network
you'd have these synapses which could be
dialed up or down by these signals it's
received which change these code these
codes
I see you and so actually one thing you
made me think of is
um with like
um what sort of types of memories in
terms of you can talk about uh
short-term and long-term memory but also
given that this is like a protein basis
for like where the memory is potentially
encoded proteins have a sort of like
term navel within a cell so how does
like protein turn over like what is the
turnover of talent and how does that
sort of fit in with your theory and
that's an excellent question and that's
um being the major limitation on the
consideration of
um biomolecules as molecular storage
molecular storage and biomolecules
because molecules have a turnover time
obviously they've had molecules Tethered
to the integrine at one end and the
outside skeleton the other its turnover
is a lot less but once we drew these
molecules to scale
then what we could see is that you could
easily imagine that
so maybe I'll just back up one step so
the the general
um update to the meshko theory which
came from this new mesh code to scale
paper was the idea of
that within each synapse there's two two
part there's three parts actually two
ordered parts one of them which is
permanently attached to the synaptic
cleft and then a mechanically operated
part which could be moving up and down
and it'd be moving up and down because
of all of these tail in Springs as you
say nicely put it which the side
skeleton will be the actin would be the
motors would be pulling up and down
and in which way that it's a it's quite
a large part of the Machinery which
should be moving so if one tailing was
to Ping off and get turned over then the
whole Machinery wouldn't suddenly
collapse right so it'd be like if you
were driving a Lobby and you got a flat
tire not your vagina Lolly I think
probably not but if we were going to
lobby and one tire burst you wouldn't
just suddenly Veer off into the ditch
because it would keep going on the
others you'd have to stop and change it
so the idea came that maybe if all of
these tailings are coordinating this
mechanically operated part of the
Machinery then it wouldn't be explicitly
dependent on every single molecule so
that would allow for turnover and it was
actually um Francis Crick in 1980 1984 I
think he said that this was why it's
hard to imagine
um protein-based memory because of this
limitation
but I think this overcomes it and that
was because when we could see what these
molecules would look like it led to this
idea that they might all be working as a
as a collective as a Machinery okay I
like how I mean
I understand like how some proteins get
degraded but do you know how Taylor
might get degraded if it is like I
should say attached is it just wear and
tear or like what physically is there
any regulation over its turnover
um I'm sure there is so
if you measure so if you measure the
turnover of tailing in in cells and
culture then there's two distinct
populations one bit which turns over
quite fast in like minutes and then one
which is more stable for tens of minutes
if you do the same experiment which was
done by another group in in Fruit play
in tiny little in the wings or the
muscles of fruit fly then what you can
see is that the turnover the tailored
molecules in the muscle is much longer
it's on the day's scale so
presumably if it's a proper ordered
system it could be much longer than that
but
all molecules will turn over like that's
part of how you maintain
um
the Integrity of the cell and that's why
when aging when you start to get defects
in that that can cause
problems where you get accumulation of
waste products or damaged proteins
okay yeah and so you like to continue
your idea about
um time scales and obviously we've
already mentioned earlier that Talent is
expressed in different cell types
um we obviously when we think about
memory we often always think about the
brain but
um if Talent is being expressed along
with these other like
um presence and fallenness uh Mesquite
theory in different cells
um do you think that there's some
elements of memory and other cell types
and by that I mean not like like
Memories how we might think of it but
like how a cell might remember how to
respond to a certain stimuli or like
um do you think it's Universal Property
of cells as opposed to it being a unique
thing that we just see in synaptic
connections
yeah so that's an excellent question so
yeah I think it's definitely a universal
property of cells and I think
besides the organization of the um
cytoskeleton and the the switches at the
bottom
um of the cytoskeleton would definitely
be in all of ourselves would be
information carrying and could be
updated by a contractility
um by switching the motors on and one of
the ideas I'd speculate in the paper is
exactly that like a lot of the like the
synapses are beautiful for doing
computation because you could send a
signal and change that mesh code which
then would update that newer one so you
could do very complex because there's a
really high complexity in the in the
wiring up of the nerve cells so that
could be for doing High computation but
then all of the cells would be operating
using what's essentially a binary code
so I called it a machine code which I
don't not Everyone likes but I think
it's a kind of like every single cell in
the body
will be operating with this mechanical
interdependency between all the cells
which would be at the base level would
be at the the binary level of these
switches so yeah I think all of the
cells and that's definitely the case
because all
all animals
even go I've done Sly mode they've seen
slime modes have been well established
to have
um a basic type of memory where they
will map out where food is and go into a
direct route and
um so I think that's an interest and
they've got the same machine I mean
Mexico Machinery so I think it's an
intrinsic
part of um What Makes Us sell so yes
yeah it's interesting yeah and so like
obviously going on for that and um
obviously studying things in human
organisms it's very hard to do for like
what um what's sort of the best evidence
so far about sort of testing or proving
that this is where the memory or the
information is being encoded obviously
we have the the structural uh uh studies
where we can see that there is a way of
encoding this information potentially
but it's a way that you can sort of
tweak it or rearrange the structure of
the the domains or like how would you
yeah what if what to use the best
evidence you have so far yes so again
excellent question so
for sure we can show on the single
molecule these are memory molecules we
can show that the Integrity of synapses
and the um the wiring upper nerves to
form these synapses that's tail
independent so the tailing is an
integral part of the scaffolding around
the cyanapses and it's a Memory molecule
obviously when you have those two
there's a there's a join up in the
Middle where is the memory part of the
molecule at play in the synapses and it
so that's the bit we're desperately
trying to test so
we're we're trying this in multiple
different ways I think the best evidence
we've got is some work we're doing in
collaboration with um a lab in Yale Tony
koleski where we're actually measuring
the length of these molecules within
cyanap within dendritic spine and we can
clearly show that the tailing is very
much longer than what it would be if it
was not stretched at all but most
excitingly is that the different spines
on the same dendrite have got different
lengths of these talings so the big
thing though is if we can come up so
it's changing its shape in the different
ones if we can correlate that to the
activity then that'll be the jackpot and
we're trying to do that at the minute
because if we can show you that the
activity both changes
and the length changes and we could get
predictive on that that would be really
important
um so that's a work in progress the
other data we've been getting
is trying to work out how to visualize
these different shape changes so make
probes which can recognize whether
certain switch is in a one or no State
and things like that and then we've also
been using
um
a technique with a group in in Sweden
where we can actually look at which
proteins have changed their shape and so
you take two two sets of neurons
is hey one set new ones you split it in
two you stimulate one half and then you
submit them both for this technique and
where you look for domains which have
changed shape and it's a type of mass
spectrometry technique and what you can
clearly show there is that the
stimulated and unstimulated they have
different patterns of um switches so all
of this is kind of slightly tangential
from each other but I'm hoping if we
bring them all together and we can show
correlate them all then that would be
good and the other aspect we've got on
the experimental is we've got a series
of
which is the new neurodevelopmental
diseases linked to mutations in
um
a few of them entailing but most of them
are in the proteins which interact with
tailing so if we can join that up and
show that these mutations are caused
because of a failure of the mechanical
regulation so I'm hoping I hope in 2023
will be the year where we can actually
um show this because we can see it now I
can physically show you um images of
these proteins at different changing
their different lengths but it's we're
still not quite nailing it yet so get in
there yes I think so one of the things I
was going to ask you about was mutations
and if there's any links with the
Caesars I said like is Taylor commonly
mutated is it like rare but lethal so
it's not very common
so up until last year I thought there
was or maybe two years ago I thought
there was no mutations in tailing and
now with the huge genomics there's a few
which have very specific diseases
interestingly that in tailing too the
other ice form there's no mutations
whatsoever so
um yet identified so it's obviously
very well considered but the things
which interact and decorate tailing
there's lots of mutations in those and
in in these in these adhesion complexes
there's hundreds of diseases caused by
mutations in them but tailing right in
the middle is so important that they're
very few and far between
um yeah that's interesting and so like
in terms of the genetic structure as
well I said you mentioned there's Taylor
one Taylor too is that there's just one
copy of each gene or it's a
yes
so the tailing 2 can have some more so
there's two copies of each of each gene
um so that there's no there's no
homozygous mutant uh tailing where both
copies are messed up but the
heterozygous ones where one copy of the
gene has got a mistake
then they have um
disease but the two tailings are
separate genes so there's no mutations
in the tail in two Gene which I'm aware
of
um and that's also the one which is in
is more brain Express so one idea is
that the two have got very similar but
then just subtly different roles in
slightly different localization that's
something else we're actively exploring
um
yeah that's interesting and like also
um because I forgot to ask Alia when we
spoke about these different there's 13
domains of telling um so what is like
the maximum in terms of binary code
amount of information that could be
implemented because is it you know is it
more complicated because we have
multiple Taylor molecules within one
so I think this is a good question and
I'm not 100 sure like
we know that the the third domain will
always open first or you know everything
we've done it's the weakest domain so
that one's always going to be at the
start
so there's a slight ordering to them
because there's some which are really
struck strong so much are very weak and
then different ones in the middle so
there's not two to the 13 permutations
because some of them won't
they won't happen in that order
um trying to get to the total number of
bits of information you could speculate
based on how many switches we think
there are and it might be
yeah I don't know it's a very short
answer but it's definitely not 2 to 13
it's probably less than that um
yeah okay and I also because you
mentioned it earlier like the fact that
not only is Taylor conserved but the
um the order of the domains is also
highly conserved which I guess yeah it's
in support of your theory that whatever
this is doing is clearly very important
yes because I think there's meaning to
that order and I think the order which
they open up
is instructive of what the change in the
signaling at that site and the change in
the length of the molecule at that site
and it must like
yeah the meaning of that is quite
um and so something which we're trying
to do with um
in-house is to try and understand the
rules of computation on a single
molecule because we can show that these
switches are opening but could we
actually answer those questions how many
states do you get and what patterns do
you get routinely and try and because
there's also a possibility of using
these molecules for for by a for
computation in like
the machine or in something else to
actually harness it for what for
computation in a buyer computer or
something but first I think there's
still a lot to do to understand
the rules of um yeah
um tailing computation and
that's a work in progress yeah
okay yeah because um well one thing that
I think would be interesting would be to
see because if it's lethal to have
um like actual mutations and talent but
um if you just sort of switch the order
of domains but that affects memory or
some sort of specific function within
the organism no that would be great the
problem is because of the so in cells
people are like one of the things which
we've also been doing which is similar
to that is that we can because we know
the structure of this because that's the
first thing we did we know what each
domain looks like on which where every
single atom in that domain is and what
we've been able to do using that
information is to make
changes mutations which stabilize the
switch or make the switch like have a
hair trigger so that's a way to sort of
change the order without changing the
order because you could make the domain
which opens first much stronger so it
doesn't open first open second or things
like that and that's been experiments
which have used those sort of mutations
that changes how cells and culture
behave so that's one way to do it and on
that note some of the
reasons why these switches open and
close is because they've got inside the
core of them inside the middle they've
got messages called syrians and
theanines which are actually where the
phosphorylations occur so enzymes
interact with those
um so one of the things which is also
very interesting is that the enzymes
change the switches and change the order
which they're opening so there's a lot
of this going on which the cells doing
intentionally
my concern is if he tried to me if you
tried to reorganize this I think maybe
in the selling culture it'd be all right
and that's something we should
definitely try that's a good suggestion
but in a
in a complex more complex system I don't
think it I think the camp the
conversation would fail it would trip
over
um because everything would be come out
disorganized
um it's likely to be lethal um as
opposed to affecting like a specific
memory function like it might affect all
cell types yes and I think a bit like I
think
because development development and
mechanic um there's a lot of
mechanabiology going on at each stage
the next stage yeah where it's already
at so if it falls over early on that's
usually lethal because when it goes to
do the next stage it's out of sync and
it and in this idea then they would just
the mechanical calculation which is
causing the development of the organism
would
have a cat stop it ever like they've
just fault it fails
they're good to try though and just
certainly trying on a selling culture or
neoning culture which should be very
durable
yeah I think that'd be good yeah I think
it'd be really interesting
um and so like with
um memory as well like there's obviously
lots of different theories about where
memories encoded how is it encoded
um based on like some of these studies
where we need tailoring's really
important it someone suggests that
taylon seems necessary for whatever
memory is but clearly by itself maybe
isn't sufficient or like do you think
there's like redundancy in the basis of
memory or like
um yeah I don't know like I said like a
backup or like proofreading or like
alternative
um it's just like talent's part of the
story but it's not the complete picture
um well Italian's part of the really
complex mechanical Machinery of the cell
and it's essential for that but it's not
working in isolation all of the things
which regulate that all of the density
of the
um receptors and the and the vesicles
being released they're all essential and
it's not just a single size that synapse
in isolation they're all linked together
and there's a lot of work on like neural
networks and these circuits information
where
um the problem I always have with some
of those ideas is that
if you it's basically like the
difference between actually writing
something on a disk and holding it in
in short-term memory like them like if
you're trying to hold every all the
ideas simultaneously
then that would take a lot of energy to
be very complicated whereas if you re
imagine the neural network each node
you've got
a set of switches where you can change
that node and capture it in a really
quantized specific way then the
reimagination of the neural net idea
because I think the idea that
and synaptic
um
signaling and synaptic strength is
reasonably well accepted as people who
challenge it but I think it's quite well
established that changes in the um
transmission through synapses is how
information is stored and here that
would be written in a more complex way
not just a symbol sim a simple on or off
it would be like there'd be more
information written in each sign up and
they would be node in a complex circuit
so it's definitely not sufficient on its
own if we have a tailor molecule in our
test tube we it very limited the number
of information we could write into it
but as part of the machinery and as part
of this complex beautiful
um
sell cell signaling which is going on
then it's a central player I think the
other Theory would suggest one thing
actually you made me think of just now
is like uh like the efficiency of the
system so obviously like things like DNA
replication protein synthesis all very
highly energetic processes within a cell
and even like synaptic electrical
transmission of the sodium ions
potassium pump that being extremely
energetic as well in terms of like how
like uh the the tail end is like
stretched and how it gets like fixed in
that position of how it changes
um like I can imagine like I was
pregnant on my head filthy like that's
to some extent that's maybe passive or
like it is there what energies required
for this process and is it therefore
linking back to how the brain is like
super efficient in terms of memories and
something that uses a lot of energy I
mean as much as I think like revising
for example this is very energetic maybe
like a lot of memory storage doesn't
actually need energy it's like just
based on sensing I don't know yeah
that's an excellent question that's
that's where I think one of the
strengths of this is because
in fact memory molecules and things
decorate them they only need like a
basal level a low level of force like
intracellular tension to store this
information and then to change the
signal you have a temporary increase in
tension so you switch a motor proton
motor protein on it pulls until the next
switch opens and then it goes back to
what's a low energy State and these
patterns because lots of they're not as
the molecule on their own like things
are sat on them and fixing these
patterns in these states
the energy is only required to update
them so when you have a synaptic
signaling event that would update this
pattern and the rest of the time it
would be held at a low energy so I think
that this is one of the big strengths
because they're also going back to the
the neural net if you constantly trying
to keep everything in in Ram you'd need
a lot of
activity neural activity to maintain
that whereas here the default resting
state would be a low energy State not a
no energy you need low energy for basic
upkeep of the cell and then the signals
will be a transient increase so I think
it's it's a much lower way to consider
um
memory I would say
okay yeah just we just have an input to
change the pattern
and so given that obviously like how
does
um Theory describes as being like a mesh
code like it isn't a glitchy a mesh in
terms of like um potential ethical
issues about how if we somehow uh
determine the molecular entity of what
memory is and like a link sort of like
memory manipulation or memory changes do
you think that that would even be
possible given what we've described like
how it's encoded and fixed and like what
are your thoughts on that yeah so
I really like the question and I think
it's
this is where you can really mesh up
against
um science fiction because the
implications of it so the Mesquite
theory is predicting that there's a
physical location for all the
information written into the shapes of
these molecules in in the synapses of
our neurons in our brain and they're
physically written to specific locations
um So that obviously leads to the
implication that potentially you could
if you understood how the code that
they're written in
then you could read that information
obviously we're nowhere near that we
don't improve that there's a Code but if
you do work that out and
with like SSD cards like electrical and
storage
um I'd like the little terabyte chip
which would fit on your fingernail like
we'll be using our phones and stuff
there the information is read back by
the electrical signal on the route it
takes back through the
um the pages of information so here
maybe the electrical fingerprint because
that's what people measure at the minute
they measure these electrical
Fingerprints of brain activity
um if that was if you could link that to
what the underlying pattern was of
information and extract it out then yeah
of course it'd be tempting to speculate
that you could read the memories
and then the obvious thing is could you
then do the inverse and write them and
again that's we're nowhere near that yet
um but potentially and then it also
leads to but then you need to understand
what this coding is it's a binary code
maybe that's what I'm arguing I think
we're binary creatures I think all
animals are
[Music]
um
could you understand that code and then
could you understand if you'd like to
consider kind of the operating system or
um
how it's written what format is are we
using and you need to understand that to
be able to retrieve the meaning but I
would say that's very
um possible and possibly once you
understand stand it so
yeah and then you get into the com if
it's a proper binary thing with a human
operating system say this is proper
science fiction now so this is detached
from
the bit we talked about which is more
grounded but if there was an operating
system with a specific
then could you upload that onto a
computer I know there's a lot of people
interested in that could you preserve
brains and recover the information
um
so then if you as soon as any of that
becomes possible then there's vast
ethical issues but I don't think
they will hit us in probably in my life
they're probably in your lifetime but I
don't know I don't know where that would
be down the track
um but yeah there would be
um but it it definitely mashes up
against science fiction and science fact
but that might be where
we could do this yeah and like given
that you we have sort of Realms into
science fiction a little bit and
speaking about like preservation I think
it was the other week I was making a
video on cryo biology and looking at how
memory whether or not if you phrase a
brain would that memory still exist and
I guess that was like the safe life in
that and understanding if there's like a
physical basis for memory and so I think
I can't remember entirely what the study
was I was looking at but there was
something to suggest that like long-term
memory was perturbed by freezing but I
don't know that might be support for
because I'm having physical uh storage
or not I don't know yes so I
accidentally got
and involved prayerfully with a there's
quite heated arguments about this on
Twitter I found that I mean people who
think you can pickle the brain and get
the information out this is very simple
they will Behavior more of this but like
the idea that you could preserve it with
um formaldehyde or some form of pickling
versus the ones who think you'd need to
freeze it and then you could like the
creative preservation then you could
warm it back up and get the information
back
um and
I would definitely be a bit more of the
that you need to freeze it and then try
and really get it going but if you could
get it so that these circuits would not
conduct electricity is a bit simple but
get them so that they would signals
start talking to each other then
potentially it could be possible it
but also and the good um
so a couple of ideas which lead from
that in terms of how we might use this
for something more useful is
if information is written in the shape
of these molecules in the synapses then
over time
if you get a bit of damage to a bit of
the synapse then you might lose that
information and it might become
unretrievable because the the patterns
it wants and owes have got out of sync
with the rest of the brain so one of the
things we're very interested in is the
is aging of the brain but more
importantly Alzheimer's disease maybe
you could imagine that these plaques or
the thing ahead of the plaque is
corrupting this information like these
Pat these a certain set of synapses
become out out of sync from the rest
and then it'd be like if you have a CD
and you scratch it you lose that
information it's never retrievable
because it's gone so
the idea that the um this mechanical
these binary switches might be getting
perturbed by these
um drivers of these awful
um loss of memory loss of Mind sort of
diseases it's somewhere I'm quite hoping
to make to them ground
at the minute but hopefully and we've
got we've got some quite nice
experiments and data which indicates
that we're on the right lines in that
boot but early days maybe you can have
me out in a couple years and I'll tell
you all about it
I don't know I'd love to I don't say
like um I was actually listening to a
lecture online about the extra cellular
matrix this morning and um one it was
sort of saying like how under research
it still sort of is I mean there's lots
of research being done but how much
there is to learn about it but it was
speaking about it in the context of
aging and obviously given Alzheimer's
disease where you have like these AMOLED
beta plaques and also like glycation and
like stiffening of the Matrix and
different uh tissues as well and
obviously if we go back to what we said
like way earlier where
um the idea of this tailing response is
that there's some sort of fixed
um you fix one part
um in the SLA Matrix and it's like the
internal response that's getting changed
if now we're changing both sides like
the Springs getting altered from both
directions and maybe it loses as you say
this ability to keep the the memory
updated and that could therefore link to
memory loss of age of course that's a
really great suggestion and what's
really going back to the the stem cell
which differentiates as you change the
stiffness test then if the stiffness is
changing because of a disease or because
of age you know because of less loss of
the type regulation of it then that's
going to change all of the mechanical
signals Downstream of that and that's
what
happens in a lot of cancers and a lot of
disease where you get a stiffener you
get fibrosis and you can sort of imagine
it quite easily with the switches
because if you were to try and climb up
a ladder and the ladder was a rope
ladder then you use a lot of work
because it's hard to overcome those to
convert into an upward movement if you
try and climb up a wooden ladder you can
go as fast as like pretty fast at
maximum speed for whatever your ladder
climbing ability is and that's because
it's much easier to overcome these four
thresholds with a stiffer my so these
switches will open much more easily if
they
um if the environment if the Matrix
becomes stiffened
if the mechanical computation is
assuming that it knows what the Matrix
is
and then the Matrix is stiffer then you
will get the wrong patterns you'll get
the wrong
um
switches opening and that is definitely
how that could happen in the Aging brain
and as it gradually loses it's High um
this super audit state which we're
predicting here and it starts to get
stiff in some parts and then that's
corrupting bits of data which then get
out of sync with others and the whole
thing so yeah I think that's a very good
point and the ECM
there's a lot to understand about that
it's really complicated
yeah no I think like I mean a lot of the
sort of Asian literature is about like
loss of information or like loss of cell
identity and obviously and look like
cancer and other examples it all does
sort of interplay with like the ECM and
and how like that's connected with like
she mentioned through accents like the
nuclear periphery and how that changes
gene expression and it all kind of makes
sense and I guess yeah the interest is
like how do we then either prevent it
from happening or if it happens how do
we identical refer to or like regain
um your credits uh
I don't think anyone's ever going to
live forever because I think when you go
through development there's like a
really beautiful ordering of it and I
think at the end of development
everything's mechanically synchronized
and everything is all
ordered together and that's where you
can spot Beauty in
um in in
young anything because they're
mechanically perfect because and they've
got their radiant skin and everything's
perfect and then over time as you get
little bits of damage or bits of changes
they slightly slightly get out of order
so this long-range synchronization of a
cell here to here and I think well maybe
this isn't a very good answer but I
think that you gradually just spiral
away from this high ordering of this
system and that sort of like kind of
impossible because it's kind of
unavoidable is this is not going to
resonate well with the anti-aging people
but it seems to be kind of inevitable
that you'll lose that long-range order I
think you could slow it down but as its
Bible's out of control and they all get
out desynchronized relative to each
other then that would lead to aging and
in the concept of neurodegenerative
diseases where you're actually losing
that information like in dementia and
Alzheimer's
then maybe there's a route to treat to
slow that down because you could stop
those plaques from stiffening it or if
there's a toxic intermediate you could
stop that from
affecting these codes quite as quickly
um so there might be new ways to treat
it which aren't anti-plaque
um drugs which don't seem to be going
too good
um
then yeah but I don't think you'd never
stop it because I think it's an
inevitable fighting against or fighting
you're fighting entropy really
yeah I it's given me a lot to think
about
um I I think the reality is at the
moment I don't think we know enough to
really argue either either way or like I
think that's yeah there's so much still
more to learn hopefully there might be
some hope but um
but yeah it's finding ways to sort of
like rough ass the damage
um or yeah see if there is a way of
recovering the information
um yes for sure
um I think slowing it down and it might
be what I would like to think is maybe
if you spotted Alzheimer's coming on 10
years sooner or something like that like
maybe there's a mark you can see that
you have got this sort of
accumulate loss of information this
accumulation of damage or this loss of
this coding then you might be able to
intercept it earlier and slow it right
down a lot a lot and because I remember
one of my teachers at Uni said you don't
need to cure cancer you just need to
stop it long enough until old age does
it does what it does like I'm saying
with the loss of memory you only have to
if you could slow it down by 20 years
then that would probably
be good enough unless we haven't live
forever and then it'd be that much my
feeling is that that would be good
enough just to slow it down and just to
preserve it as long as possible yeah and
that's how I'd like to try and think we
might make a dent in that
yeah so um I guess well that area is
still being resized one thing that I
thought as a bit of a Sidetrack was um
applications of this knowledge of
understanding how Talent operates I saw
another recent paper why you were
describing uh telling us like a shock
absorber and using it in like different
materials I would say I mean I haven't
really explained too much but would you
go to elaborate on like what's next in
the tail and space besides looking at
just uh the Mastery Theory so
yeah so that was a really nice
um
side spin-off from what we were doing
because when we were stretching the
single molecules were tailing we and
measuring a tail and how it behaves in
cells you could clearly show that it's
sitting it serves as a shock absorber
because if you pull really fast then
these domains opening up introduce a lot
of tension in which makes the Force drop
and then it starts to accumulate again
then the next switch Falls so you it
buffers Force really effectively and we
showed that in a in a paper in 2016.
um
so each of these Taylor molecules is a
shock absorber so then I've got a
chemist friend downstairs who um Jen
hiscock
um and we were just having a chat one
day and the idea came about I said we've
got these shock absorbing proteins and
she said
we could make a protein-based material
where we take the tail in as a monomer
or polymerize it so we link together
I don't know trillions and trillions of
copies of some of these switches and to
see whether you could capture that um
nanoscale shock absorbing on a material
Level
um and the short answer was yeah it
worked and it worked
way better than what we predicted and it
was these materials have got this
fat um it really captures it they
and it makes sense because you've got
all of these switches which are doing
little tiny shock absorbing but loads
them polymerized like joined together
into a big gel and the the nicest
experiment there is what my PhD student
did for one of his final experiments
where our PhD students sorry
um where we we've got a master physics
department downstairs and they've got
one of these Light Gas guns which is
longer than this room which fires
um like space dust they use it for but
tiny little bits of sand Basalt
particles
uh um 1.5 kilometers per second so we
put our bit of gel in and then we fire
it down and the cool thing was that the
gel was still intact but then when we
put it onto the microscope we could see
all of the projectiles embedded in this
so that was quite exciting to the
physicist because they want to capture
this stuff to study it um because this
spaced us
from what I gather up and talk to them
is a massive problem for spacesuits and
the International Space Station and
stuff because it it's with him around
the earth and whacking into them and you
don't need to go through their the visor
of the spacesuit so we're currently
doing a lot of work on trying to develop
that into a
to scale it up and to make that into a
new type of material a shock absorbing
material using what we know about
tailing so that's
um a side project of what I do the main
thing is I think is to understand
the mesh code I mean that's my passion
and that's where I think we can make the
biggest difference and if we can prove
that there's a binary code in animals
that'd be really cool and the the
different diseases which are caused by
um my dog has got epilepsy and we've got
um a pretty well nailed down link
between mechanical signaling and
epilepsy now and so if I could help
contribute to epaulette then what we
know about epilepsy that'd be really
nice
um and besides that just to carry on
understanding this molecule because it's
so amazing and I've spent the last 15
years working on them maybe even longer
working on the same molecule to try and
understand what it does and every time
we do a set of experiments they
certainly could see a different set of
what it's doing and what it's how it's
operating so I think the main goal of my
research is to carry on working and
understanding Taylor
um as this memory molecule in all
animals
well like yeah I hope you do because I
mean what you've published so far is
super fascinating and I'm Keen to see
some of these experiments come out so
just to kind of like I guess wrap up
um our conversation I was just wondering
if you could give any sort of like
advice for maybe younger scientists
obviously you've now got a very
impressive career and done some really
great research like
um what do you think uh what sort of key
values that you sort of took along with
you
um
um a really good question so yeah to be
very to persevere I think it's really
hard and to be persistent and to work
hard I think that's a given
um and to be nice to people because I
really try and I the best thing I like
about this game is collaborating with
people and collaborating people are
really good at what they do so I know
the bits I can do and then collaborating
and building these Personal Collection
connections with people I think that's
really
my number one tip like um the I think at
Google's motto like don't be a dick I
mean it's just true it's nice to be open
and I try and be as generous as I can
and I try and be
fair in collaborations I don't want it's
not about winning honest man because
we're trying to do something much bigger
than that so I think to work hard and be
nice and to just
yeah there's a lot of ups and downs and
I I had a very security route till I got
onto tailing because like when I was
doing my PhD and I had my supervisor he
died sadly he died in a car crash so
then I had to move and change projects
and then my first postdoc we got scooped
on and that's the fear of all scientists
I think but
um and then so I had a very very slow
start it's like I don't know four years
after my PhD when I got my first paper
um
and then going into us in into industry
learned a whole new set of skills to be
organized because I wasn't very
organized before and I'm slightly less
less
slightly better than I was before
um
yeah that's probably my advice just be
nice and work out
um I spent a lot of time thinking about
the same thing
for better or worse but um yeah I mean
do you read quite widely
um yeah like you're obviously really
well read it's been very impressive
there so I think really and also go to
seminars because we always have problems
drumming up everyone to go to them but
seeing stuff which isn't in your field
um is really important a whole one about
we've got a million pound Grant offered
talk where we went to look at something
on amyloids which I don't work on but
this missing piece of the puzzle and
then you write it and your sleeves
so yeah I think going to seminars is is
a good tip as well because even if it's
not a very good seminar you learn about
why it's not very good or your dreams
you always learn something from the
seminar I think
yeah I should probably get some more
seminars
um yeah and it's always like oh I'm so
busy but if especially if they allow you
to eat your lunch in there then it's
almost like a freebie and that's true
but even they give us pizza now baby
yeah
cookie at the end and then you'll be
there so yeah and that may not be very
good advice but that's probably
I think no I think that is good advice
and do you have any like specific books
or anything that you would like
recommend uh people to read
um
so I I read a there's a really good book
on Cell Biology by the numbers
um
I think this one's amazing
oh I added that to my Amazon basket like
literally last week well that's a good
one and then there was when I first
started getting into mechanical memory
and I started to Google
um and look into it in a bit more
serious moving away from looking at cell
migration to start and think about
memory there's a fantastic book by
I forget the first author's name but
Randy galisto and it's on the um
computational mind and it's out it
basically it doesn't provide any answers
but IT addresses the the need for
um a read write memory in in animals to
be able to do computation you've got to
have a read write memory so I read that
um I used to I just read it on flights I
don't read it the best time but just
read it when I'm playing and learned a
lot and it sort of helped to formulate
the ideas I had into a framework which
made sense
um
so that's another really excellent book
yeah those two actually oh great okay I
will definitely buy that book at some
point yeah for Christmas because it's
really it's a good it's well written and
it's just fascinating to just think
about how many molecules there are how
long they are because
they don't really talk about in there
but the drawing the the mesh code to
scale which is in that new paper that's
where we suddenly could see why why that
would work and also to see that these
molecules don't look like what they're
drawn in textbooks where they're all
these nice pretty little circles it's a
totally it's very good for communicating
an idea but it's not so good for
actually understanding what they might
be doing because it's it's not it's not
accurate
yeah that's completely true
um I'm kind of guilty yeah I didn't read
this book basically
um
yeah so why can't my fears go if they
want to like learn more about your
research or get access to some of your
your papers
say that again where could they go to
find out more about your research and
your Publications
[Music]
um
well I would start with either the mesh
code papers if you Google mesh code then
it's it's pretty high up on the list
topics
um and that's that's the idea out I
tried to write those
in a way well my dad helped me about
those a lot and he he's a he was a GP
but he wasn't he was a coal miner and
then he became a GP and back in the days
where there was social Mobility
um but
um to read it so that they could
understand it and so that people could
understand it because obviously it's a
complex idea
um and I think I tried hopefully I got
they worked I mean that I would read
those two to start with or my Twitter
account yeah
I don't use it that often I'm not a
it's not a heavy user so it's it's quite
light
okay great I'll put some of those links
in the description
um so yeah thank you for everything as
much like one more thing on that um so a
lot of these animations because one of
the big things I'm trying to describe
this I'm just doing this sort of useless
hand actions one of the things we
realized was to actually visualize this
we should make animations of what's
going on so with Sam Barnett um who was
the um who wrote the mesh code scale
with me we actually made a series of
animations which were on my YouTube
channel which show what these memory
molecules look like and what memory
written in in the shape of a molecule
looks like so that's quite good because
they're only like um 15 or 20 seconds
long each so but they just show a
specific thing which we're interested in
so that's another good place to look
yeah I can fast for that because I
watched them myself and the different
girls um so I'll link that to you um so
yeah thank you Ben for coming on
um yeah it's been a really great
conversation and I'm super interested to
see some of your Publications when they
come out
um and learn more about this mess code
Theory brilliant thank you Ellen that's
been a really excellent chat okay so I
hope you've learned something in this
video thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening